[موسيقى]
ثم وطابت اوقاتكم هذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء نبداها بابرز العناوين
وثائق البنتاجون المسربه تربق على تواشنطن
بحلفائها وتكشف ان الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ستتوقف قريبا
بعد عودته من الصين ماكرون يطالب
الاوروبيين بالابتعاد عن واشنطن ويدعو الى
قطب ثالث
التاسعه هذا المساء تكشف مواقع القصف
الاسرائيلي في سوريا ردا على استهداف
الجولان المحتل
يتوعد الديمقراطيين ووزير العدل السابق
يكشف انه تم تحضيرهم من مشاكل قانونيه قبل
مغادرته منصبه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اذا ضعف او ارهاق عسكري على
الاقل يشكو منه الجانبان الاوكراني
والروسي وفق الوثائق الامريكيه
المسربه وثائق البنتاجون كشفت مدى عمق
اختراق الولايات المتحده لاجهزه الامن
والاستخبارات الروسيه اختراق استخباراتي
سهل لواشنطن تمريره معلومات مهمه الى
اوكرانيا حول كيفيه الدفاع عن نفسها حيث
حضرتها بشكل يومي بشان توقيت ضربات موسكو
المخطط لها واهدافها المحدده وكذلك تقديم
تقييم لقوه اله الحرب الروسيه وفق واشنطن
بوست الوثائق صورت الجيش الروسي على انه
منهك في حربه في اوكرانيا ووصفته بالجهاز
العسكري المعرض لخطر كبير التقييم
الامريكي لم يظهر الجيش الاوكراني بوضع
افضل
حاله ان يرثى لها مع نقص حاد ومقلق في
ذخائر الدفاع الجوي الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه تكافح لمجارات الصواريخ
الروسيه وفقا لاحدى الوثائق قدره اوكرانيا
على توفير دفاع جوي متوسط المدى لحمايه
الخطوط الاماميه
ستنخفض تماما بحلول 23 من مايو مقبل
محللون عسكريون ارجحوا تاثيره التسريب
سلبا على ساحه المعركه والحاقه اضرارا
كبيرا بجهود اوكرانيا الحربيه من خلال منح
موسكو فرصه محتمله لقطع مصادر المعلومات
الوثائق المسربه من البانتاجون تكشف
معطيات صادمه
توقل امريكي كبير في الجهاز العسكري
الروسي والاوكراني
[موسيقى]
الوثائق اظهرت قدره واشنطن على تحذير
اوكرانيا بشان الضربات المخطط لها من
روسيا وتقييم اله الحرب الروسيه
الوثائق ترسم صوره للجيش الروسي المتهاوي
الذي يكافح في حرب اوكرانيا
وتكشف نقل المعلومات الحساسه الكياف
للدفاع عن نفسها من خلال تحديد توقيت
الضربات واهدافها
الوثائق تظهر ان عملاء واشنطن يخترقون
تقريبا كل الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه
مسؤول استخباراتي غربي قال ان التسريب
مؤلم وقد يحد من تبادل المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه
[موسيقى]
بئر الاسرار المفضوحه قد يهز ثقه الحلفاء
بالولايات المتحده وقدرتها على الاحتفاظ
بمعلومات حساسه في خزانه سريه
تسريب الوثائق التي فاقع عددها المائه وفق
ضابط استخبارات عسكري بريطاني متقاعد يثبت
فشلا امريكيا على اعلى مستوى مضيفا ان
الضرر لن يتحدد حجمه على الفور فيما بشرت
وزاره العاده للتحقيقاتها لمعرفه كيفيه
التسريب المواد المصنفه سريه للغايه الا
ان اصابع الاتهام توجهت تلقائيا الى روسيا
او عناصر مواليه لها دون اعطاء المزيد من
التفاصيل
التسريب الاستخباراتي وصفته صحيفه
ديليجراف بالاسوء منذ قضيه ادواردن من هو
هذا الشخص وما قضيته
عمل كمتقاعد كمتعاقد عفوا مع وكاله الامن
القومي قبل ان يسرب تفاصيل برنامج التجسس
الذي يهدف لمراقبه ملايين المواطنين
الامريكيين الى الصحافه في يونيو 2013
هرب الى موسكو عاش فيها لاجئ سياسي منذ
عشر سنوات اي بعد التسريب وقد منحته روسيا
جنسيتها العمل الماضي
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤولون بكوريا الجنوبيه انسول على
علم بالتقارير الاعلاميه المتعلقه بتسريب
العديد من الوثائق العسكريه الامريكيه
السريه وتعتزم مناقشه واشنطن في القضايا
التي اثارتها التسريبات
وذكرت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز انا الوثائق
المسربه تحتوي على تفاصيل حول مناقشات
خاصه بين كبار المسؤولين في كوريا
الجنوبيه حول الضغط الامريكي على بلادهم
للمساعده في امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
وقالت الصحيفه وافقت على بيع قذائف مدفعيه
لمساعده واشنطن على تجديد مخزونها مصره
على ضروره ان يكون المستخدم النهائي هو
الجيش الامريكي
معنى من واشنطن عبر سكايب بشار الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي سيد بشار اهلا بك يعني
هذه التسريبات كيف ستنعكس على علاقه
واشنطن بحلفائها كيف سيثقون بها مستقبلا
وهذه المساله للامانه ليست في الجديده
قضيه الثقه بين واشنطن والحلفاء لان حريه
التجسس والتجسس المضاد اضافه الى قضيه
التسريبات ليست بالجديده في علاقات
الامريكيه الخارجيه حتى ما اقرب الحلفاء
نعلم كان هناك عديد من حالات التجسس التي
شكها من حلفاء منها المانيا مثلا عندما
كانت فضيحه تجسس على على الهاتف الجوال
للمستشاره الالمانيه ايضا
فضيحه اخطر
في مقدمه النشره هذه الاخطر منذ عهد سنودن
ولكن فضيحه سنودين كانت في عهد من في عهد
اداره ديمقراطيه كان الرئيس الحالي نائبا
للرئيس بمعنى هذه ثاني فضيحه تسريب من
نوعها
تهز صوره امريكا امام الحلفاء وامام
الخصوم ايضا
التوقيف ايضا محرج للغايه لانه تزامن مع
تصريحات للرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون بعد لقائه
الزعيم الصيني ويتحدث فيه عن القطب الثالث
ايضا الفضيحه تكتسب بعدا في غايه الحساسيه
بالتوقيت بنسبه هجوم المضاد لاوكرانيا
الذي متوقع كما قال برينكن ان يبدا في اقل
من اسبوعين كلها تكبر الى ازمه مركبه
تواجه اداره بايدن وتزيد من احراجه امام
الحلفاء طيب هل هي ربما تكون اوراق وقد تم
الانتهاء منها البعض مقاديرها بهذا الشكل
ومن ثم تم حرقها البعض الاخر بيحمل
مسؤوليه كل ما جرى الى الولايات المتحده
من انها افقدت على الاقل اوكرانيا مثلا
خطوه متقدمه من انها تعرف كل تلك
التسريبات عن الجيش الروسي مثلا
المضامين تظهر ان هناك خرق هذا الخرق
الاختراق بصرف النظر النتائج فيه حساسه
ومدمره هو لا يتعلق فقط في اوكرانيا هناك
بعض الانباء تتعلق اشرتم في الملف الكوري
وهذا ملف ملتهب لانه على تماثل فقط في امن
شبه الجزيره الكوريه وانما ايضا بالعلاقات
بالصين بالتوقيت الذي يحاصر فيه الجيش
الصيني الان تقريبا جزيره تايوان ايضا
اساس بالنسبه لاسرائيل الحساس بالنسبه
لايران ونحن نعلم يا عزيزي تذكر ان من
فضيحه الوثائق المسربه التي تم العثور
عليها في جراج سياره الرئيس بايدن في
داروير كان من ضمنها اسباب تتعلق في ايران
واستعدادات لمواجهه ايران كل هذا ياتي في
توقيت تتنبا فيه ايضا الاستخباريه
الامريكيه وعلانيه بان ايران قد تحاول
القيام بعمل ما يمس في الامن الاقليمي
الواقعيه تقول انه طالما بقي الرئيس بايدن
واداره ديمقراطيه بالحكم للاسف الصوره
تضعضعت وفقدت كثير من الهيبه امام العالم
والاهم من ذلك الصوره الداخليه عزيزي
الكونغرس الان يباشر بالعديد بالتحقيقات
بالذات مجلس النواب رئيس اللجنه
الاستخبارات في مجلس النواب الامريكي كحزب
جمهوري قال ان ما جرى في غايه الخطوره
واستدعي التحقيق فهذه تحقيقات المتتاليه
ليست فقط تهز من صوره بايدن الخارجيه هذا
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه في امريكا
عندما تكون قرارات استخباريه في هذه
الخطوره في ملفات في غايه الحساسيه تتعرض
لاختراق ويتم تداولها اين عبر منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي هذه ايضا تذكر بكيفه
فقد السيطره عندما صارت تويتر بقياده
ايلون ماسك الذي يتحدث علانيه بان هناك
محاولات لتعتيم بعض المعلومات عن صانع
القرار الامريكي والمواطن الامريكي لا
ينبغي ان تبقى هكذا دون ان يعلم بها خاصه
عند الاستحقاق الانتخاب شكرا جزيلا
للكاتب والمحلله السياسيه بشار جرار من
واشنطن
ثلاثه عشره طائره ميجا 29 تعاهدت سلوفاكيا
برسالها الى اوكرانيا الشهر الماضي وحجزت
حينها مقعدا متبرع الاوروبي الثاني
بمقاتله بعد هولندا غير ان سلوفاكيا في
موقف محرج حاليا لا تحسد عليه فطائراتها
تعيبها اعطال تسبب بها تسبب بها فنيون روس
كيف ذلك وزير الدفاع سلوفاكي اعلن عند
الطائرات المقاتله التي تم تسليمها
لاوكرانيا معي قادره على الطيران لكنها
عاجزه عن تنفيذ مهام قتاليه وفقا للتعبيره
الاجزاء المعطله الوحيده في الطائره
الحربيه جميعها او جمعها تقنيون روس عملوا
في قاعده القوات الجويه السلوفاكيا حتى
العام الماضي وفق دالي تيلغراف بموجب
اتفاق طويل الامد مع روسيا تمركز الفنيون
الروس في سلوفاكيا لامتلاكهم معرفه اكبر
بالطائرات السوفيتيه مقاتلات اميغا 29 وهي
طائره اسرع من الصوت وهي من الجيل الرابع
قدرتها مذهله المناوره والوصول للاهداف
واطلاق الصواريخ من مسافات بعيده كفاءه
هذه الطائره بالمعارك يعتمد على عده عوامل
اولها العدد لما في ذلك من اثر وفعاليه
اما العمل الاخر فيعتمد على خبرته
اوكرانيا في استخدامها وتوفير قطع غيار
يمكن استخدامها
[موسيقى]
نبقى في الجو حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان طائره سوخويا 34 استهدفت جسرا
في تشيرني هيفا الاوكرانيه وذلك لمنع قوات
اوكرانيه تابعه للمخابرات من التقدم
باتجاه الاراضي الروسيه ومنطقه
الحدوديه بالتحديد
اشار وزير الخارجيه الاستونيه اولماس ارين
ايرين سالو الى ان السلطات بلاده قد تشتري
مقاتلاتنا امريكيه من طراز 16 وذلك بعد
تسلمها الى اوكرانيا فيما نفى البيت
الابيض الشهر الماضي وجود خطه لدى واشنطن
لتدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على مقاتلات
اف 16 في الوقت الراهن كما اعتبر الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن حينها ان تزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات امريكيه ليس اولويه لدى
ادارته في الوقت الحالي
في كييفا عادت منظمه تنقذ اوكرانيا 31
طفلا اوكرانيا من روسيا ليجتمعوا بدويهم
الاطفال الذين تمت اعادتهم جزء من اكثر من
16 الف طفل نقلوا الى روسيا اثناء الحرب
ووفق سفير اوكرانيا لدى الامم المتحده لكن
روسيا كان في هذه الاتهامات قائله انها
انقذت اطفالا اوكرانيين من اهوال الحرب
[موسيقى]
بعد عودته بساعات من الصين وفي احداث
تصريح يظهر الخلافات بين واشنطن وباريس
شدد ماكرون على ضروره ان تقلل اوروبا من
اعتمادها على الولايات المتحده وان تتجنب
الانجرار الى مواجهه بين بكين واشنطن بشان
تايوان ماكرون قال ان الخطر الكبير الذي
قد تواجهه اوروبا هو الوقوع في ازمات ليست
ازماتها مؤكدا انه ليس من المصلحه اوروبا
تسريع ازمه تايوان وبناء موقفها بالتبعيه
للولايات المتحده او بتلميحات من الصين
معتبرا انه في حال اشتدت التوترات بين
هاتين القوتين فلن يكون لاوروبا الوقت ولا
الموارد لتمويل استقلالها الاستراتيجي
واضاف ماكرون ان على اوروبا تقليل
اعتمادها على الدولار الدولار الامريكي
خارج الحدود الاقليميه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع في تايوان انها رصدت
احد عشر سفينه حربيه صينيه وسبعين طائره
في محيط الجزيره فيما تجري الصين مناورات
عسكريه لليوم الثاني وذلك بعد محاكاه
لضربات دقيقه ضد اهداف رئيسيه اجرتها في
المياه المحيطه بالتايوان
التوتر الامني الى جانب السياسي خيم على
مضيق تايوان في ظل المناورات التي تنفذها
الصين لليوم الثاني على التوالي ما ينذر
بامكانيه حدوث المواجهه في اي وقت
الصين ماضيه في مناورات عسكريه حول جزيره
تايوان ردا على زياره رئيسه تايوان
للولايات المتحده ولقائها مسؤولين
امريكيين
فاين بالتحديد تلك التدريبات الصينيه وما
حجمها بحسب مصدر امني تايواني فان
التدريبات الصينيه تقع حول قناه باشي التي
تفصل تايوان عن الفلبين وتضمنت التدريبات
الصينيه محاكاه لضربات دقيقه على اهداف
رئيسيه في تايوان ولتطويق الجزيره بالكامل
كما نلاحظ هنا محاكاه ثلاثيه الابعاد
نشرتها القناه الصينيه الرسميه
وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه تقول انها رصدت
مقاتلات صينيه من بينها مقاتلات 30 وقذفات
اتش سته فيما باتت المواجهه وشيكا حيث
توجد عشر سفن صينيه ومثلها تايوانيه على
خط المواجهه بالقرب من الخط الاوسط
للجزيره
[موسيقى]
طيب في اكدت انها لن تسهم في التصعيد
لكنها توعدت بالرد بالشكل الملائم على
تدريبات بكين
في حين قالت واشنطن حليفه تايوان انها
تراقب المناورات الصينيه عن كثب مؤكده
انها تمتلك ما يكفي من موارد وقدرات لضمان
السلام والاستقرار بالمنطقه
قال السيناتور الجمهوريه لانسي جراهام ان
الولايات المتحده يجب ان تنشر صواريخ كروز
نوويه وتطلق من البحر في المحيط الهادئ
لردع الصين
واضافهم انه منفتح على ارسال قوات
الامريكيه الى تايوان للدفاع عن الجزيره
قائلا ان الغموض الاستراتيجي لا يجدي نفعا
وفق تعبيره
ينضم الينا من باريس مصطفى المحلل السياسي
سيد مصطفى ليبدا اولا من زياره ماكرون
وهذا التصريح له عن فك الارتباط على الاقل
بالولايات المتحده ومواقفها سياسيه
والتصعيد مع الصين الى ماذا يشير هل تعبت
اوروبا وفرنسا على الاقل من طوال مده
الحرب وطول هذه الحرب
في اوكرانيا وروسيا نعم نعم يجب الاشاره
هنا الى ان هذا تصريح غريب ومفاجئ نوعا ما
خصوصا من طرف الرئيس الفرنسي لانه عندما
كانت هناك ولا زالت حرب روسيا اوكرانيا
كان الرئيس توقف الرئيس الفرنسي عن الحديث
عن ما يسميه بالاستقلاليه الاستراتيجيه
وشاهدنا ان فرنسا ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي
كلها عادت الى الحضن الاطلسي ومدوت تحت
الرايه الامريكيه ومن ثم هذه الحرب التي
نعيش نراها في على الفضاء الاوكراني بين
العالم الغربي الاطلسي وروسيا لذلك الكل
كان يعتقد بان الرئيس الفرنسي من الباكرون
قد دفن نهائيا او على الاقل مرحليا هذه
الفكره هذه العقيده الاستقلاليه
الاستراتيجيه بعد ان التقى الرئيس الصيني
وهو في عودته في طريق عودته الى فرنسا
يطلق هذه التصريحات التي تعيد يعني موقف
فرنسا وعقيده فرنسا الى مربعها الاول انه
يجب على فرنسا الا تكون وعلى دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا يكونوا تابعين هيكليا وعسكريا
للولايات المتحده وعليهم ان يفكروا في
استراتيجيه استقلاليه استراتيجيه ويفكر
حتى هنا في الدفاع اوروبي موحد هل على
الاقل اوصل من خلال هذا التصريح الى الصين
او اعطاء الصين اشارات بانهم لن يساعدوا
باي باي اتجاه من الصين الى الى تايوان
سيبقون على الحياد لن يقفوا مع الولايات
المتحده وهذا التصعيد
نعم ما فهمناه من الرساله الفرنسيه ومن
ورائها الموقف الاوروبي ان تايوان هو خط
احمر امريكي ولكن ليس خطرا احمر اوروبيا
وانه اذا غدا اندلعت مواجهه عسكريه بين
قوسين بين الولايات المتحده والصين بسبب
تايوان فان الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي لن
تكون شريكه في هذه المعركه العسكريه
العملاقه وهذا ياتي ايضا يعني ليس على
المستوى العسكري ايضا فقط بل حتى على
المستوى الحرب التجاريه هنا اريد ان اذكر
بان الرئيس الامريكي جوبيدا حاول ان يجيش
الاوروبيين ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي في حربه
التجاريه ضد الصين وكانت هناك عده مواقف
متحفظه من هذه الحرب ولا تريد ان تنخرط في
هذه الحرب العملاقه التجاريه والاقتصاديه
بين قطبين مهمين هم الصين والولايات
المتحده هل الرئيس الفرنسي يترجم على
مستوى العسكري ما كانت دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي اتخذته كمواقف على المستوى الحرب
الاقتصاديه هذا شيء يمكن يعني ان نقر به
حاليا ولكن ما هو مفاجئ ان يستعمل الرئيس
الفرنسي هذه الكلمات وهذه المفردات التي
تتناقض تماما مع التحالف العسكري المتين
الذي يربط حاليا دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده في مواجهه روسيا عسكريا
في اوكرانيا طيب هذا هل يتبعه ربما مواقف
سنشهدها في التغيرات مستقبلا بالنسبه
وبالتالي دول الاطلسي
صراحه يعني انا هنا اتوقع ان تكون هناك
خلافات في المقاربات الاوروبيه تجاه هذه
المواقف لا ننسى فقط هناك ربما خلافات فقط
فرنسيه المانيه وخير دليل على ذلك انه في
المانيا مثلا عندما ارادت ان تسلح جيشها
بعد الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لم تختار
السلاح الاوروبي وانتهكت كل قواعد التضامن
الاقتصادي والعسكري الاوروبي وذهبت واشترت
وتسلحت امريكيا وهذا يعطينا فكره بان
الالمان لا يتفقون تماما مع الفرنسيين في
هذه النظره التي تريد ان تفعل عقيده
دفاعيه اوروبيه مستقله عن المظله الاطلسي
لذلك انا اتوقع ان يكون الرئيس الفرنسي لا
اقول انه يعني يغرد خارج الصرب ولكن ربما
قد تكون هنا قوى داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
تعارض مثل هذه المواقف الواضحه اتجاه
الولايات المتحده واتجاه الصين شكرا جزيلا
يا سيد مصطفى طوسه المحلل السياسي من
باريس
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع في سياقها ولكن بعد
قليل
نسبه تحميل عاليه لتطبيق في امريكا
وتحذيرات من تيك توك ثالث
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله ردنا على اطلاق قذائف صاروخيه
باتجاه هضبه الجولان المحتله غارات شنتها
القوات الاسرائيليه على الاراضي السوريه
تل ابيب حددت اهداف هذه الغارات داخل
سوريا وبينها مواقع عسكريه عده في محيط
دمشق والقنيطره شملت مجمعا عسكريا تابعا
للفرقه الرابعه دون انباء عن اصابات
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي اكد ان
طائراتهم استهدفت منظومات رادار مصادر
العربيه كشفت ان الطيران الاسرائيلي
استهدف بغاره جويه موقعا لجماعات مواليه
لايران في محيط قريه ابو قاووق
وسع بيري في دمشق الجنوبيه لاستهدافات
شملت مواقع مدفعيه لقوات النظام وجماعات
ايرانيه بمحيط قريه الكوم وسريه صيدا
الجولان في محافظه
القنيطره اضافه الى سريه عابدين وسريه
معربه الواقعه
بحوض اليرموك
الواقع جنوب سوريا وفقا لمصادر العربيه
ياتي ذلك عقد عقب اطلاق ثلاث قدائر
صاروخيه من سوريا نحو هضبه الجولان المحتل
حيث اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان اثنتين منها
وقعتها في منطقه مفتوحه وقديفه اخرى
اعترضت اعترضت من قبل الدفاعات الجويه سبق
ذلك اطلاق اكثر من 30 صاروخ من جنوب لبنان
باتجاه اسرائيل لم تتبنها اي جهه لهذه
العمليه عمليه الاطلاق لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انها نيران فلسطينيه لا
تلقف ميليشيا حزب الله وراءها
[موسيقى]
نبقى في سوريا لكن في الملف السياسي اعلن
السفير الروسيه لدى دمشق لكزندرائيه عن
تاجيل اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه روسيا ايران
تركيا وسوريا الى اوائل شهر مايو المقبل
وقال ان الاجتماع الذي كان من المقرر عقده
يوم غد الاثنين تم تاجيله مشيرا الى ان
الاتصالات والمشاورات مستمره بين الاطراف
المعنيه للوصول الى نتائج ايجابيه في هذا
الاطار
تمضم الينا من موسكو كاتيا طعمه مراسله
العربيه كاتيا اهلا بكيه ما سبب هذا
التاجيل هل من انباء عن لماذا اجل هذا
الاجتماع الربا
مرحبا عادل حقيقه
خلال الاجتماع الاخير الذي شهدته موسكو
لنواب وزراء خارجيه كل من تركيا وسوريا
وايران وروسيا لم يتم الافصاح عن موعد
جديد لعقد قمه على مستوى او لقاء على
مستوى وزراء خارجيه الدول الاربعه ولكن
كان هناك من الجانب الروسي كما تحدث وزير
الخارجيه الروسي التي فاق او عرض اكثر من
موعد ليتم عقد خلال هذا الموعد هذه هذه
اللقاء ولكن يبدو انه حسب حسب ما تحدث بعض
الخبراء انه لم يتم الاتفاق على هذه
المواعيد حتى الان او على صيغه لعقد هذا
الاجتماع على مستوى الوزراء الخارجيه طبعا
كان قد تحدث وزير الخارجيه
مرارا ودع الاطراف الطرفين السوري والتركي
ان يكون هناك مرونه بالتعامل بينهما
بالاضافه الى ان يكون هناك طبعا الج الى
الطاوله دون ان يكون هناك شروط مسبقه كما
تحدث وزير الخارجيه الروسي قال ان هناك
العديد من المشاكل لدى بين الجانبين ويجب
ان تبقى خلف ابواب المحادثات وبالتالي
الجلوس منذ للبدء بمحادثات التي اعتبرها
هي ليست بالسهله وان هذه هي فقط الخطوه
الاولى وهو بانتظار الاطراف الاجتماع مره
اخرى في موسكو لانها هي تقوم برعايه هذه
المحادثات ولكن يبدو حتى الان عادل انه لن
يتم الاتفاق
لعقد مثل هذا اللقاء على مستوى او وزراء
الخارجيه بين الاطراف الاربعه في موسكو هل
تم تسريب اي معلومات حول التعنت احد
الاطراف او ربما طرح على الاقل شروط جديده
في على طاوله التفاوض كاتيا
حقيقه هو هذا عدل تاجيل لربما ياتي في ظل
الشروط التي تضعها دمشق امام انقره وهو
اشاره اولا الانسحاب من الاراضي السوريه
او شمال السوريه وايضا محاربه الارهاب
وهذا الذي لم يبدو انه لم يتم الاتفاق
عليه حتى الان مع الجانب التركي وبالتالي
حتى الان لم يتم الاتفاق على عقد لقاء
جديد كما ذكرت لك بين الاطراف الاربعه
ولذلك كان قد دعا وزير خارجيه ان يكون
هناك عقد للقاء جديد دون ان يكون هناك
شروط مسبقه موسكو حصلت على نصوص من كل
الاطراف قال ايضا الدبلوماسي الروسي انه
يجب البدء على اساس هذه النصوص التي قدمها
كل من الاطراف الثلاث
المناقشات وبالتالي يمكن فيما بعد التوصل
لامكانيه التطبيع بين انقره ودمشق فيما
بعد يعني هناك ارضيه مشتركه فيما بينهم
على الاقل تقوم منطلقا لروسيا في اجراء
هذا اللقاء المرتقب للحوار
او الجوله الثانيه
كما قلت لك
الجانب الروسي هو راعي لهذه المحادثات كما
كان يرعاها في الجولات السابقه ولكن في
السنه هي الان صيغه متشابهه او تشبه صيغه
السنه التي كانت تعقد
في وقت سابق ولكن الان تعقد هي فقط مع
الجانب من الحكومه دمشق لذلك هناك ارضيه
المحادثات السابقه ولكن الشروط او الشروط
التي تضعها دمشق بالاضافه الى رغبه انقره
بان يكون هناك تطبيع مع دمشق شكرا جزيلا
لكاتيه طعم مراسله العربيه من موسكو
[موسيقى]
الحكومه الاسرائيليه صحه المعلومات التي
جاءت في وثيقه مسربه نسبت لوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه والتي تتحدث عن دعم قياديين في
الموساد للتظاهر ضد الحكومه وقال مكتب
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو في بيان ان
التقرير كاذب ولا اساس له من الصحه الا ان
البيان لم ينفي صحه الوثيقه شكلا الا انه
شدد على بقاء مساد بعيدا عن اي نشاط سياسي
في غضون ذلك اكدت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
انها فتحت تحقيقا بخصوص الوثائق المسربه
التي تهدد امن البلاد
طلب زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا ايرلا
بيت رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو بمصادره
صلاحيات المتعلقه بالحرم القدسيه من اتمار
بن جفير واكد لبيد عقب لقاء جمعه بن
ثنياهو انه يدعم اي اجراء امنيه تقدم عليه
اسرائيل ردا على الهجوم الصاروخي الاخير
الا انه شدد على رفض المعارضه لقراره لقله
من منصب وزاره الدفاع وفي وقت لاحق اكد
حزب الليكود ان اختار ممارسه تافهه في
الوقت الذي تحارب فيه اسرائيل على ثلاث
جبهات
قال في السودان نفى مسؤول بقوى الحريه
والتغيير مسؤوليات القوى عن خلافات الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع التي عطلت توقيع على
اتفاق السياسي النهائي في السودان ونقلت
صحيفه الجريده السودانيه ان جوهره خلافات
الطرفين يتمحور حول المدى الزمني المطلوب
للعمليات الانتقاليه اذ يطالب الجيش
بعامين بينما تتمسك قوات الدعم السريع
بعشره اعوام بالاضافه الى اشتراط قوه
الدعم السريع تنفيذ الاصلاحات داخل
المؤسسه العسكريه قبل دمج قوتها
[موسيقى]
وصل وفدان سعودي وعماني الى صنعاء لبحث
جهود احلال السلام وتراس الوفد السعودي
السفير محمد ال جابر الذي التقى الصحبه
رئيس الوفد العماني التقى القيادي الحوثي
مهدي المشاط اللقاء سيبحث تمهيد الهدنه
والعمل على اجراءات لبناء الثقه واختبار
التوصل الى حل سياسي شامل في اليمن
هذا ونشر منصات تابعه للحوثيين
مقطعا لهذه الزياره واللقاء كما تشاهدونه
حاليا
كشفت صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه ان تلويح
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمراجعه
علاقاتها مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
العام الماضي بعد قرار اوبك بلس تقليص
انتاج النفط لم ينفذ ابدا وان التصريحات
في حينه كانت بسبب الحرج الامريكي من قرار
اكتوبر من عام 2022 وبكي بلس فاجات العالم
بخفض الانتاج بمعدل مليوني برميل يوميا
امريكا اعلنت معرضتها للخطوه والسعوديه
مضت قدما فيها اتهامات للرياض بالوقوف في
صف بوتين وتهديدات امريكيه بمراجعه
العلاقات مع السعوديه
وبينما كانت الولايات المتحده تراجع
علاقتها مع السعوديه كما تقول مضت المملكه
في طريق مصالحها الامنيه والاقتصاديه رؤيه
2030 للامير محمد بن سلمان تطلبت استقرارا
سياسيا السعوديه وايران اتفقتا على اعاده
العلاقات بوساطه الصين الرغبه في استقرار
سياسي بالمنطقه يقود الى نماء اقتصادي
وتامين خطوط امداداتها الى العالم
صحيفه بوليتيكولا الامريكيه كشفت انه وبعد
مضي سته اشهر من التصريحات لمراجعه
العلاقات مع السعوديه لم يحدث شيء وان
حديث بايدن عن العواقب كان سببه فقط
الشعور بالحرج من خطوه اوبك بلس الصحيفه
اكدت ان اداره بايدن لا تستطيع الاستغناء
عن السعوديه وانها لم تجري اي مباحثات
جديه لمراجعه العلاقات معتبره ان زياره
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه غير
المعلنه للرياض جاءت في سياق استعاده
العلاقات القويه مع السعوديه
ارتفاع كبير بمعدلات تحميله حققه تطبيق
لمن ثمانيه تابع لشركه باي بالانس الصينيه
ملكه تطبيق تيك توك في الولايات المتحده
مؤخرا
التقارير التقنيه كشفت ان التطبيق استغل
الازمه الحاليه ليصعد القمه متجاوزا بذلك
تطبيقات عملاقه كواتساب وفيسبوك وجيميل
ويوتيوب ونتحدث هنا عن معدلات تحميل هذا
التطبيق في الولايات المتحده طبعا خبراء
تطبيقات السوشيال ميديا علقوا على هذا
التصاعد بان التحميل الصاروخي ثمانيه وهو
حيله ذكيه من الشركه الصينيه للتخلص من
الضغوط الامريكيه التي ترغمها على بيع تيك
توك او مواجهه حظره واضاف الخبراء ان
الشركه الام لتيك توك
ومستخدمي تيك توك بشكل رسمي وبدات في وضع
خوارزميتها على هذا الاساس لتكون قادره
على اشتداب الاعداد الضخمه على تيك توك
وبالتالي نقلهم الى ثمانيه
فيما يتخوف مسؤولونه امريكيون من قدره هذا
التطبيق على التجسس وتحميل المزيد من
بيانات الامريكيين وارسالها للحزب الشيوعي
الصيني تطبيق ثمانيه الذي اطلقته يشبه
بشكل كبير تطبيق انستجرام وكيفيه عمله وما
اعتبره البعض خطوه تنافسيه لانستجرام لمن
ثمان هي
هو عباره عن منصه منصه وسائط اجتماعيه
لمشاركه الفيديو والصور تلبي اهتمامات
المستخدمين في الطعام الجمال الصحه وكذلك
السفر
فوضى عارمه في علامات التوثيق الزرقاء
تسببت بها منصه تويتر منذ ان بدات تطبيق
قرارها بازاله العلامه عن كل من يرفض
الدفع مقابل منح تلك الاشاره التي لطالما
كان الحصول عليها متعبا لمن يدفع بعض
الدولارات بينما لم يكن بمقدور اي شخص كان
الحصول عليها قبل استحواذ الى ماسك عليها
وبعد تطبيق القرار متى يصعب التفريق بين
الحسابات القديمه الموثقه لشخصيات عامه
مثل باراك اوباما وحسابات التوثيق
المدفوعه شهريا وبالتالي قلل القرار من
قيمه تلك العلامه وفقا للخبراء بمنصات
التواصل الاجتماعي بالمقابل اعلن الكثير
من الشخصيات الشهيره ومنهم نجم كره السله
الامريكيه ليبرون جيمس وصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز انهم لن يدفعوا اشتراكا مقابله
تحويل علامه الطائر على صفحتهم من اللون
الابيض الى اللون الازرق
نشرتنا مستمره والمتابع في سياقها ولكن
بعد قليل ناصر القصبي يقود طاش العوده الى
قلوب السوداني قال بتسمح لي لانك
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله نستكمل التاسعه من ملف محاكمه
ترامب حيث حضر وزير العدل الامريكي السابق
من ان المشاكل القانونيه الحاليه قد تؤثر
سلبا على حظوظه في الانتخابات القادمه
مشيرا الى انه اي ترامب حفر لنفسه فجوه
فيما يتعلق بمجموعه القضايا القانونيه
التي يواجهها اتهمها الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب الديموقراطيين عبر منصه تروس
بتدمير امريكا كما وصفهم بالحزب اليساري
الضعيف الذي يسعى لتدمير المجتمع الامريكي
بالعوده الى الرئاسه مشيرا الى ضروره
الغاء التصويت الالكتروني لانهاء الاحتيال
على اصوات الناخبين والاعتماد على التصويت
الورقي فقط على حد تعبيره
[تصفيق]
الرئيس الامريكي السابق فاز على الممثله
ستورمي دانيالز باحدى الجولات القضائيه
واستخدم اعتقاله بقضيه شراء الصمت كدعايه
ناجحه لحملته على الانتخابيه حتى اللحظه
فما الجديد في التحقيقات
تحقيقان جنائيا اخران يشاركان على
الانتهاء الاتهامات فيها كبيره ليست فقط
ضد ترامب ولكن ربما عشرات او اكثر من
حلفائه وفقا صحيفه نيويورك تايمز اول
التحقيقين يركز على جهود مزعومه قام بها
ترامب لقلب نتائج انتخابات 2020 في ولايه
جورجيا فيما الثاني يتعلق بهجوم السادس من
يناير على مبنى الكابيتول
مايكل كوهين المحامي الشخصي السابق لترامب
اكد ان توجيه الاتهام الى الرئيس السابق
يخدم المسائله والعداله لكنه فظيع بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده على حد التعبيره
بالحزين مضيفا انه سيعطي نظره ليست بجيده
للحلفاء والاعداء معا باعتبار انه اول
رئيس في التاريخ الولايات المتحده يتم
اتهامه
يذكر انكو هنا اعترف امام هيئه محلفين
كبرى بانهم مذنب في اتهامات تمويل الحمله
الانتخابيه بمساعدته في ترتيبات السادات
السداد عفوا
تبادل الانتقادات في الاسابيع الاخيره لا
سيما ان الاخير وصف توجيه الاتهام الى
ترامب بالضروريه لانه يحتاج الى ان يحاسب
على افعاله القذره وفقا وصفه اذا كانت هذه
هي الطريقه التي تظهر او تظهر بها الحقائق
على حد قوله
بعد ان اكتملت اركان الخطه غادر تومب
منزله في فلوريدا تحت الاضواء
بث مباشر على كل القنوات ومئات الانصار في
الشوارع لتحيته اقامته في نيويورك كانت
محسوبه بالدقيقه اما خطواته المتثاقله
التي قادته الى القاضي فقد كانت جزءا من
بروفه تفاصيلها اعدت مسبقا مصدر من داخل
البيت اكد ان المتهمه ناقشه طويلا مع
دفاعه السلوك الامثل اثناء المحاكمه
تعابير الوجه ولغه الجسد كانت كلها تصب في
اتجاه مشهد واحد الضحيه والجلاد
ايام بعدها جاء دور الاخراج تروم نشر مقطع
فيديو يروي في اقل من دقيقه قصه رئيس سابق
خضع للقانون رغم براءته المسبقه
[موسيقى]
المقطع شاهده الملايين وبات واجهه الحمله
الانتخابيه
المترشح يتجه تدريجيا لاستهداف مشاعر سكان
وسط امريكا ضد البرياليه واشنطن ونيويورك
اما انصاره فقد ازداد تشددا خاصه بعد ان
انتصر في قضيه اخرى امام دانييلز بعيدا عن
نيويورك محكمه كاليفورنيا الزمت الممثله
الاباحيه دفع مبلغ قدره 600 الف دولار
تعويضا عن بطلان ادعاءها بالتعرض للتهديد
استغل القضيه وطالب بالمزيد من اموال
المتبرعين اكثر من ثمانيه ملايين دولار
جمعت فقط لدعمه امام القضاء لكن العوده
للبيت الابيض مشروع يلتهم المال دون حساب
تحول محاكمه منهه الى دعايه انتخابيه لم
يعد مساله جدليه في امريكا لكن قدره ترامب
على استماله الاصوات المتارجحه تحدي اخر
يلزمه تقمص دور المنقذ لا ضحيه يجر وراءه
المشاكل
قالت قناه فوكس نيوز ان مجلس النواب
الامريكيه يعمل على استدعاء رؤساء بنوك
وشركات للتحقيق بسجلات ماليه تخص هنتر
بايدن نجد للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
واشارت فوكس نيوزي الى ان التحقيقات التي
ستجريها لجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب
ستركز على سجلات نجل بايدن الماليه
[موسيقى]
انهت الجهه المعنيه في السعوديه
استعداداتها لبدء الخطه التشغيليه في
المسجد الحرام للعشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان
ياتي ذلك تزامنا مع الاعداد الكبيره
المتوقعه ان تشهدها اروقت المسجد الحرام
من الزوار والمعتمرين حيث تعمل جميع
الجهات للمشاركه في خطه على تسهيل دخول
المعتمرين والزوار الى الحرم المكي
ومغادرتهم وفق الخطط المعده مسبقا وبكل
راحه وسهوله
معنى من الحرم المكي المراسل للعربيه
اسامه القاسم اسامه حياك الله اليوم نحن
نتحدث عن استعدادات كبيره ما هي الاعداد
المتوقعه استقبالها خلال العشر الاواخر
خاصه ان هذه الفتره حتى من بدايه رمضان من
الليله الاولى والثانيه كانت هناك اعداد
كبيره تزور الحرم المكي
اسامه اقول لكم الصوت والصوره اليوم من
اعلى منطقه في الحرم المكي الشريف وهي سطح
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه طبعا توسع
السعوديه الثالثه اليوم بخمسه ادوار وهذه
الصف تم اعلان استكمال جميع اعمال تهيئتها
لاستقبال الزوار والمعتمرين في العشر
الاواخر وايضا تم اعلان ذلك في بدايه شهر
رمضان المبارك طبعا هذه التوسعه توسعه
السعوديه الثالثه تستطيع تحمل اكثر من
مليون مصلي في اليوم الواحد طبعا نتحدث
اليوم عن هذه النقاط الكثيره جدا عن
التجهيزات التي قدمتها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
نحن الان ننقل لكم الصوت والصوره اثناء
اداء صلاه التراويح وسوف نستعرض لكم الان
ايضا صورا للمطافه المطاف العلوي بادواره
الثلاثه وايضا الساحات الخارجيه والادوار
الخمسه المتواجده اليوم في التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه عادل ونحن نتحدث اليوم
عن هذه الجهود الكبيره ممثله في وكاله
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بالتاكيد
لاستقبال المصلين خلال العشر الاواخر من
خلال منظومه من الخدمات الميدانيه
الهندسيه الفنيه ايضا تنفيذ الاعمال وفق
خطط تشغيليه وكوادر بشريه من مهندسين
وفنيين ومراقبين وعماله يعملون على مدارس
الساعه لراحه وسلامه قاصدي المسجد الحرام
طبعا نتحدث اليوم عن تنفيذ هذه الخطط في
ادوار مبنى التوسعه كافه ايضا تهيئه
الساحات التي نشاهدها الان من جميع
المحاور والممرات القادمين من جميع
الانفاق سواء انفاق جرول او جبل الكعبه
حسب حسب الخطط المعده للعشر الاواخر من
رمضان بالاضافه ايضا الى تكثيف عمليات
النظافه والتعطير على مدار الساعه والتاكد
ايضا من تشغيل مشربيات ماء زمزم وتامين
الحافظات وتجهيز الابواب وتامين السجاد
كنا بالامس ايضا تحدثنا عن فتح ست ابواب
اضافيه للمصلين
غير الابواب التي تم افتتاحها ايضا من
بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك اضافه الى تشغيل
نظام الاضاءه الداخليه والخارجيه وكل
انظمه الصوت وفاعليه وتجهيز مداخل ومخارج
من والى التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه عادل
اليوم الاعداد وصلت الى
حوالي 17 مليون زائر ومعتمر بالتاكيد ان
العشر الاواخر ستشهد ازديدا في اعداد
المعتمرين والزوار الاعداد التقريبيه التي
تاتي في اليوم الواحد من 800 الف زائر
ومعتمر الى مليون و200 الف زائر ومعتمر
بالتاكيد الاواخر ستشهد تزاحم شديدا
بتقديم ايضا هذه الخدمات هذه اسامه يعني
يدفعني الى سؤالك يدفعني الى سؤالك عن
طريقه تسهيل خروجهم وطريقه دخولهم الى
الحرم المكي ايضا عن عمليه التاكد من
التصاريح
نعم عادل طبعا الابواب المتاحه
للدخوليه سته ابواب باب الملك عبد العزيز
باب الملك فهد باب السلام باب الزبير باب
العمره وباب الفتح فقط اما باب المخصصه
للصلاه هي باب 87 و88 و89
و91.74 هذه مخصصه للصلاه والاخرى مخصصه
للدخول الى صحن المطاف اما من ناحيه
التصاريح نحن نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن جهود
وزاره الحج والعمره المتمثله عند ابواب
الدخول الى ساحات المطاف بالتاكد من
التصاريح بوقت التصريح وتاريخ التصريح
ووقت دخوله الزائره والمعتمر الى صحن
المطاف عشان بالنسبه انه يتاكدوا هل فعلا
هذا الزائر او المعتمر جاء وفقا للخطه
الزمنيه لدخوله الى صحن المطاف امنه جاء
متاخرا او مستقدما ايضا الحد من من يدخلون
بدون تصاريح وشاهدنا جهودهم ايضا خلال
ايام الماضيه خطه التفويج من خلال اداره
الحشود والتفويج الموجوده في رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين من اجل ادخال واخراج الزوار
المعتمرين وفي خطه ممنهجه لدخولهم واخراج
عن الابواب ابواب الدخول الى المطاف تغلق
اثناء الصلاه لكي لا يتداخل المصلين ايضا
بالمعتمرين وهذه بالتاكيد خطه تحسب لرئاسه
شؤون الحرمين والوكالات المسانده هذه
الصوره مجددا صوره لاثناء اداء الطواف
لبعض المعتمرين وايضا الصلاه في هذه
المصليات الموجوده في ادوار التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه نتحدث ايضا عن تكثيف عن
هذه الجهات وعن تكثيف هذه الجهود في
الايام القادمه وبالتحديد في العشر
الاواخر توقعات بان تزيد اعداد المعتمرين
بنسبه اكبر مما صارت عليه في العشر ايام
الاولى والعشر ايام الثانيه جواك الله يا
اسامه واكيد راح نكون معك بهذه التطورات
لمعرفه الجديد شكرا جزيلا لك تقبل الله
طاعتك
[موسيقى]
في عالم الدراما الخليجيه ظهر الفنان
الكبير ناصر القصبي مرتديا ازي السوداني
مستخدما العاميه السودانيه ليكسب قلوب
الشعب السوداني حيث اشتهر بشخصيه سودانيه
فريده عكس عكس من خلالها تعامل واخلاق
السودانيين والقضايا التي تهمهم في طاش
العوده كما فاجا الجمهور باسماء ومعالم
ومفردات موغله في العاميه السودانيه نتابع
في الماده 82 قال بتسمح ليوم
كانت وما زالت الشخصيه السودانيه حاضره في
اجزاء سلسله الطاش اجاده النجم نصر القصبي
للعاميه السودانيه جعلت شخصيه الزول عثمان
التي يؤديها من الاقرب لقلوب السودانيين
ناصر قدم الشخصيه بشكل كويس
ودي الشخصيه اللي نحن قاعدين نشوفها مثلا
في روايات الطيب صالح وقاعدين نشوفها في
في الشخصيات السودانيه المتقدمه يعني نحن
شفنا الانسان السوداني هو كبير الاخصائيين
وشفناه وهو مهندس كبير جدا وشفناه ومحاسب
وداء ارجع لامانتو لصدقه اتمنى اشوف شخصيه
ناصر القصبي في واحد من السماسره اللي
يجيدوا البيع والشراء لانه عنده حنكه
في الكلام جميله جدا
زين تقليدي يتميز به انسان شرقي السودان
ويعرف بالسديري اما الجلابيه فهي زي قومي
كما العمامه يرتديها الرجل السوداني في
مختلف المناسبات ناصر القصبي او الزرع
عثمان اصبح حديث شارع السوداني تعالوا مع
بعض نشوف اراء شارع
حفرجك على واحد من القصبي
اشتغل مع لانك
القرش ما بيطلع منك يا سلام كل يعني
المتفاجاه واكيد الشعب السوداني
اجانب ما بيطغرل ولا كلمه يعني زي ما هو
اجاد اللهجه حقتنا السودانيه دخل قلوبنا
باللهجه السودانيه اللي بيقدمها لنا كل
سنه وبعدين نظره بحاجه في الموسم ده لما
قاعد يقول لنا
حرم حرم
ة ضحكت اكثر كلمه ضحكتني لما قالت تعرفت
على وحده في الفيسبوك حبيته وحنتزوج
وحطينا جرس
يعني حرفيا انا حسيت بس ده ده زول الي
بيقدر بيجسد الشخصيه السودانيه صح لانه
يعني الشخصيه السودانيه صعبه
العوده تفاعلا كبيرا نتابع بعض ردود
الافعال
العزاب شنو انتم
لا والله
ماما شافت وعد
وعدس تجننوه كده
اسكت ساكن
والله والله
ما ببقى ولد ابوي
دقيقه زياده
[موسيقى]
عدد المهاجرين الذين يعيشون في فرنسا عام
2021 بنحو سبعه ملايين اي 10.3% من السكان
وفق دراسه ديموغرافيه نشرت مؤخرا ترصد
لاول مره منذ عشر سنوات تطور الهجره على
مدى عده اجيال وكشفت الدراسه ان اكثر من
ثلث هؤلاء حصلوا على الجنسيه الفرنسيه بعد
وصولهم
اهلي صالون حوالي اربعين سنه بفرنسا انا
مولود هون نشا اسامه في عائله فرنسيه من
اصول فلسطينيه السوريه كانت قد هاجرت منذ
عقودا للعيش في فرنسا ورغم انتمائه الوثيق
للبلد الذي ولد فيه الا انه لم يتخلى يوما
عن جذوره الاصليه ام حافظين على قيمنا
يعني اهل يعني كتير اشتغلوا على موضوع انه
يعني
يرسوا فينا
القيام الاسلاميه والقيام العربيه وبهمنا
دائما انه يكون عنا ارتباط بحضارتنا
تبقى فرنسا في طليعه الدول التي تعتبر
قبله للمهاجرين في العالم عراق مختلفه
عبرت من هنا وعاشت على ارضها لتمتزج بنسيج
شعبها وتصبح جزءا لا يتجزا من هويتها
الديمقراطيه عشره في المئه من سكان
فرنساهم مهاجرون هذا ما كشفته دراسه
ديموغرافيه جديده اجريت لاول مره منذ عشر
سنوات ويلاحظ الخبراء الذين اشرفوا على
الدراسه ان المهاجرين في فرنسا اكثر
ارتباطا بالدين من بقيه السكان بحيث يحتل
الاسلام المرتبه الاولى
الهجره هي ظاهره تاريخيه كانت حظيره دائما
في فرنسا نلاحظ انه منذ عام 2000 بدا
الارتفاع في نسبه المهاجرين في السكان
الفرنسيين ولدينا ايضا زياده في الهجره
لاسباب انسانيه ظهرت خاصه منذ ازمه
اللاجئين في عام 2015 قبل خمسين عاما كان
اغلب المهاجرين في فرنساهم من جنوب اوروبا
اما اليوم زاد تنوعهم وياتون بشكل اساسي ا
من المغرب العربي وافريقيا واسيا وتشكل
النساء نصف عددهم زينه العربيه باريس
وثائق البنتاجون المسربه تربك علاقتها
واشنطن بحلفائها وتكشف ان الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ستتوقف قريبا
بعد عودته من الصين ماكرون يطالب
الاوروبيين بالابتعاد عن واشنطن ويدعو الى
قطب ثالث
التاسعه هذا المساء تكشف مواقع القصف
الاسرائيلي في سوريا ردا على استهداف
الجولان المحتل
ترامبيه عادل الديمقراطيين ووزير العدل
السابق يكشف انه تم تحذيره من مشاكل
قانونيه قبل مغادرته منصبه
نشره المساء انتهت لكن اخبارنا بمستمره
بالتاكيد بعد قليل 360 ساعه اخباريه
مختلفه مع طاهر دائما طاهر
اهلا بك
شكرا
ماذا لديك في الملفات ابرز الملف سنه
تناوله يعني محاوله ماكرون ان يبتعد مجددا
عن المسار الامريكي بعد عودته من بكين
ايضا موضوع المناورات الصينيه والتصعيد
مجددا في الملف التايواني ارجو ان تكون
معنا بكون معك يمين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات